je me suis excusé
excusez moi de vous déranger au milieu
des applaudissements je m'excuse mais
excusez moi de vous déranger mais voilà
j'ai j'ai eu une démarche très difficile
à faire je voudrais vous demander une
aide ou un secours ou les deux à la fois
si possible ou bien dans l'espèce qui
serait le mieux bien sûr les espèces
aérienne mieux que les espèces alors si
vous voulez enfin monsieur vous voyez
bien que je suis gêné la visionner et
bien pas tant que moi monsieur si vous
savez comment jugez vous savez vous
savez je ne refuse jamais d'aider les
gens quand je peux oui mais je voudrais
bien savoir à quel titre
d'autant plus que je n'ai pas l'honneur
de vous connaître ben oui mais je suis
alors je suis gêné c'est pour ça que je
suis gêné alors expliquez moi mais je
vais vous expliquer voilà monsieur voilà
monsieur monsieur je suis un artiste
sans prétention jeu et sans confort au
nahd je peux vous dire que j'utilise un
très grand musicien un très gros budget
mais je n'ai pas de chance je n'ai pas
de chance tout ce que j'entreprends dans
la vie dans l'art dans la musique ne me
réussit jamais j'ai pas de chance je
suis guignon pas un pur à sa reconquête
et scoumoune a comme un régiment de
malchance
oh là là là là ça fait beaucoup pour un
seul homme
oui ça fait beaucoup de bouches à
nourrir surtout à leurs gardes alors
voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai pas de
chance je voudrais que vous me donniez
c'est possible vous m'aidiez et pourtant
je suis musicien je voudrais que vous
m'aidiez par un petit chèque non barret
c'est possible ou alors ou alors des
billets de 10 ou 50 mais des 56 lemieux
qui a si vous avez de 50 ya pas mieux
que ça attendez attendez attendez vous
avez de 50
non non c'est trop mesquin n'avait pas
dit non non non on m'avait dit vous
étiez musiciens oui monsieur mais ça ça
m'intéresse mais j'ai pas de chance
monsieur rien ne me réussit dans la vise
j'ai confiance ça me réussit pas mais je
vous assure ça me réussit écoutez ne
vous découragez pas à laisser mois ferme
et comment vous êtes musicien mais de
quels instruments jouets vous de quel
instrument je joue
oui mais enfin vous jouer peut-être du
piano de la guitare de la batterie
non moi je joue pas le jeu moi je joue
je joue la viole de gambe de la cua
d'art viole de gambe à hadera viole de
gambe et très bien attendez moi un
instant je reviens sur si vous avez de
50 c'est mieux ou en espèces parce que
de 50
voilà monsieur est ce que vous pouvez
pas me jouer un petit morceau en
attendant qui s'appelait de derrière les
fagots 6 mai non merci ça j'ai pas
besoin
voyez monsieur la dig que j'ai vous
voyez la poisse que j'ai monsieur je
vous ai dit que j'étais digne eux vers
eux monsieur je vous ai dit que je
souhaite la viole de gambe et vous a
réussi à trouver le vieux de campagne
ces enfants réfugiés kurdes qui jouent
la roma tristesse et dans mes
partenaires et mes dents mais lyon
m'avait donné un télégramme pour vous
j'ai oublié dans mes préoccupations
j'avais pas que ça passait par la junte
et les grands pour vous tenez prenez le
puis c'est tout mais ne partez pas
peut-être que c'est un mandat on sait
jamais les miracles grâce à dieu oulala
c'est encore mieux commandes à deux
mandats
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle à vous
annoncer d'ailleurs je vais vous lire le
texte oui arrive et d'argentine
stop grande vedette internationale stop
susanna raynaldy away est prête à
chanter
stop elle attend en coulisses stop
alors il faut qu'on lui jette la place
stop oui mais ça c'était pas dans le
télégramme oui mais faut partir quand
même